各位觀眾朋友大家好
哇 今天台灣股市不得了了
為什麼不得了
今天台灣股市最後尾盤
殺了400多點
很多人會想要知道尾盤為什麼殺433點
第二個
機體三大巨頭
被控碾斷
是不是利空
第三個重點是吧
7月
臥貝這場1萬點
是呀不知道我的重點搞錯了
還有特斯拉無人計程車量產
這三個重點
為什麼
我今天順便多送一個重點
第四個重點
好不好就剛講的特斯拉
特斯拉的那個
無人計程車
這量產
這四大重點
我得一次講清楚啦
同朋友
今天行情你一定要把握住
因為你要去想件事
今天節目如果你錯過
如果7月1日長1萬點
你一定會後悔莫及
那會不會長1萬點
我得跟你講
台股今天一口氣大漲快
1600點
真的如投資長所說
上週五的低點
44454點
很難再跌破了
而投資長的標股
真的很強
今天环球金直接喷上涨停啦
还有投资长的盖牌股
我爱美元和台湾No.1这两档股票
也都攻上涨停
真的太强啦
投资长早就告诉大家
不用紧张
现在拉回就是要找买点
很多人都好奇
这波到底是真反弹还是假反弹
因为毕竟台股这波涨势是全世界最猛的
如果是真反弹
究竟还有什么股票可以买进呢
接下來就交給我們經濟日報選股冠軍記錄保持者
同時也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲
最受歡迎的分析師
國者榮投資長
投資長好
Lily 各位朋友大家好
到底是真反彈假反彈
我最後跟大家講
我說過很難直接V轉有沒有講
有
台股今天攢1000多點
說好是吧
已經比我想像中攢很多
所以你不要因為尾盤
尾盤去尾盤怎麼樣
殺400多點
哇 你覺得他很遜
他已經很強了
他已經很強了你知道嗎
是
很多人想知道說
尾盤為什麼能殺433點
我告訴你為什麼好不好
好
我是外資啊
我一定要用權重去調整
譬如說
尖叫台灣股市的位階
如果別家的股市都要破底了
這樣講好了
來看清楚喔
別家的股市都在這邊附近
那我在這邊
你懂嗎
那他就會開始賣
卖貴的
你知道這邊
自己家這邊的股市
就會賣
這邊可能會買
也可能會賣
你懂不懂
懂
會賣貴的
買低的
股票不是這樣子嗎
是
股市怎麼樣必勝之道
你知道嗎
買低賣高嘛
你聽懂嗎
懂
所以我們來看一下
就韓國股市的位置
有沒有看到
師傅我說的
韓國股市是不是現在的位階
就在上禮拜五
在韓國股市
我把這放大喔
韓國股市現在的位階
是不是在上禮拜五的一個低點附近
是
台灣股市現在這邊耶
沒有錯吧
好
所以我剛才就說的
你會賣怎麼樣
賣比較貴的
買比較低的
你在看什麼
台灣股市有沒有看到
現在已經基本上
今天一度把上禮拜五的跌幅都收斂了
是
都不是收斂
都收復失土了
把上礼拜五
给的地方都收复师徒了
这是第一个
来
第二个
来来来
第二个我要讲是说
你再看一下日本股市
看日本股市哦
战国股市我们拉远一点点
看日本股市
日本股市比较好一点
上礼拜的师徒对不对
怎么样
收复一半
只有台湾在这边
台湾在这边
来就给你看这边
我們來看一下
韓國在這邊
這是韓國嘛對不對
對
這是日本
沒錯吧
台灣如果今天沒有這個
沒有這個下影線
沒有這個下影線的話
就是沒有3400多點的話
台灣會在這邊
沒錯吧
沒錯
代表很高啊
所以台灣 日本 韓國
台灣太高了 所以就把他殺到這邊來
你懂不懂 就這麼簡單而已
不要嫌太多 好不好
所以換句話說就是我說的
很難直接創新高
今天如果你跟我說
會不會載一萬點
我覺得現在有點難度
可是你說七八千點呢
難度比較小一點點
不是不可能
突破五萬點以後就有可能
突破五萬點大家瘋了
我現在在監情沒那麼瘋喔
這監情還有機會可以漲
當然我不會
但不是每一個月都每次都漲個1萬點
這太扯了你知道嗎
是
我只會跟你講機率不高
但不是不可能
如果來個七八天間點的話
不是不可能
可是首先要突破5萬點
那會不會突破5萬點
可是我要告訴大家
點數越高
風險一定高
就像我講的很多人說
哲哲
人家喊一萬塊啊
欸 賣隔離耶
你是以前聽過他的暱稱嗎
叫賣給你啊
笑死人啊
真的賣給各位啊
一千是怎麼叫你
有本事一千是給你目標價一萬塊嘛
TPU今天變成要搶到訂單
又不是今年才知道的事情
去年就知道會搶到訂單的一些公務位啊
是不是
不像實實在話
那很多人說
你今天賣錯了
我怎麼賣錯
你看一下我的一個進出表
價格表
這普通
這是特購會員而已喔
簡訊會員而已喔
我們第一次賣是賣4270元
第二次賣3880元
破底了為什麼不走
我總共大概賺136%
沒錯吧 合起來136
我第一次賣4270元
今天有比較高嗎
同朋友
第一天沒有比較高
同朋友你們有一個想法
就像我被動元件我賣了以後
它還在漲
然後咧
再找別的就好了
哲哲 你不是說被動元件下去嗎
我說老實話
他真的今天創新高 我很佩服
這籌碼實在太厲害了
可是我告訴大家
這沒有什麼
股市哪有什麼永遠賣在最高點
你如果相信這種老師
我跟你講 說我每次都賣最高點的
我跟你講一件事
只有兩種人
一種是神跟神棍
神 你可能很難遇到它
神棍你能遇到
你知道嗎
你要相信這種東西 我辦法
好不好
我告訴你 我國際就是賺了100%
100%左右
這都是實在在的話
我至少我跟別的老師不同的地方是
我是實在在可以賺100%的老師
我的股票是可以一倍又一倍的
一倍又一倍 這是賣出的績效
還沒賣納科還沒賣掉
環球金還沒賣掉
所以我們難練一下以後
我告訴你今天記憶體要大擴產了
這個利空到底是不是利空
我們一次講個夠
我們來看一下
來喔
黃小青今天暫停嘛對不對
對
讓我看一下
黃小青今天要暫停喔 你看
你看之前730我是不是說過
我是要請我播重播啦
你幫我找一下
是不是這次回答25%
在這裡回答25%
每一次只要回答25%那邊
再看一下喔
回答25%
有沒有看到
有
回答25%
在這邊回檔25%的時候
我們賺大錢
在這邊又回檔25%之後
那時候我沒買 我買的用力
這一次我也說這個買點有沒有看到
直接有點跳空拉上去漲停
去扯不扯
真的耶
昨天還在又跌停 又是跌停
又是25%之後回檔
我說商務法則是那一種
就是有時候基優股35%你就可以買了
回答30%到35%
可是有些根本就超強的股票
因為大盤莫名其妙拖累的股票
25%就可以買了
我們講環球金最經典的
回答25%就買了 有看到
25%就買了
你不買至少不會在25%之後停損
或停利
你看看之後730元買進行道
跌停板
跟昨天都很像
都快12塊跌停板了
730元有沒有看到
那時候有沒有看到
我們掛鐵艇買進有沒有看到
除了新會員以外
已經持有環球金老會員
也可以十三加碼
有沒有看到
這兩個都加碼有沒有看到
9個展停板
10個展停板
11個展停板
12個展停板
有沒有看到
13個展停板
恭喜選美小姐
6488環球金
股價表現不錯
大展公共展展停
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺
80% 我持續考他
35% 獲利虛報
6月30號
禮拜二
他穿了82%
我問大家一件事情
我一堆股票
我愛美元今天好像也展平是不是
你看 你幫我念一下
好
恭喜
我愛美元
股價強勢攻上賬廳
我持續看好他
手上持股
獲利續報
恭喜大家賺大家錢啦
我們跟YouTube最大的差別
你知道什麼差別嗎
我們跟網紅最大的差別
你知道什麼嗎
有人覺得分析師算網紅不一樣不一樣
分析師跟網紅最大的差別是
只要我夠準
你就會來看我的節目
我們是專業取勝
你懂嗎
所以我們要保護去因而每一個人
我愛每人平一命就常常暗示你們
今天也噴上展鏈盤
我吃去看好他 算是貨利區吧
你要就這樣老師
來 我們來看一下
我們今天來
直播 我們歡迎一下我們的直播人數
看一下
都看一下大家的回應
點一下
來
想看哲哲請不要酸
謝謝
我愛美人
頭轉預言真的很神
有啊 我說不要
不會說很直接V轉嘛
多轉的OK嗎
這個比較不先
儘管會亂
不是啦 你這跟儘管會沒關係
這跟進晚會沒關係
這是證交所的規定
環永慶無限關
環永慶我覺得好像關得特別快
可是我沒有看那個
因為那個管理規則非常繁雜
我不懂
所以我就不要亂講
好不好
這遇言神真的很佛
節目真的越來越精彩
都跟你講清楚
那我跟你講
我剛才的文章
我要更正一下
我怕有人覺得說
這遇在跟你胡扯
我們剛才的更正
也就是說
這邊的低點不會破
是在60秒節目講的
不是在今天的節目講的
不好意思
不是在昨天的節目
昨天節目好像沒講
這低點不會破
60秒有講
所以你看今天就談
就是說禮拜五的低點不會破
現在看起來不會破
也不
看起來而已
看起來
可是我告訴大家
這個就像我講的
蘋果這個漲價利空
還在持續發酵
你看
很多人罵記憶體
結果有沒有
南韓大投資
你們說我怎麼樣
哇塞
我在這邊
故意提高價格
是不是還有人說要告他啦聯手台價有沒有看到讚美遭遇集體的訴訟好不好有沒有看到好那這怎麼辦甚至要找中國的產商
南韓大投資全球機體
壓力測試
要砸5182億美元
擴散
很誇張
機體就這樣子
缺的時候很缺
不缺的時候很不缺
那就需要這些機體
好
那就是你看
十年和東
十年和西
所以有時候這樣子
所以整整已經經過多少
30年了
東西東
三次了
什麼東西啊
就是什麼都看慣了
你知道2008年的時候
2008年之前的時候
大家又把機體當神了
2008年的時候
一些機體什麼貿德什麼的
像有聽過嗎
你應該沒聽過吧
一堆到時候的機體
到時候都嚇死了
沒想到2023年的時候
美觀的機體
還是毛利率也會負的
結果現在沒人到
因為AI的關係需要
但是需要 我的AI有時候好像失智症
你知道嗎
一會兒記得我是誰
一會兒不記得我是誰
你的AI也會這樣子嗎
好像有時候會
也是會這樣子好不好
是不是
今天大展
所以我們看網友講的話
今天大展又不看
又不看者太現實了
細節者國際讓我賺300%
你賺300%
不太可能吧
200多元買吧
因為不太可能
來
我國際挺多讓你賺1-200%
一、兩百百分比
再跟大家講
投資上好
我是會員
為什麼沒有收到美元買進
收到我還美元買進去
你這個
第一個
有可能是最近
你應該最近加入的會員對不對
應該是喔
好不好
應該是
我不可能
你不能這樣講
有時候股票上去了
我不是你想買
你聽懂嗎
或下去了
我覺得現在買不是時間點
好不好
你看我們會員
都很實在的
這個正常的抱怨我都可以接受
好不好
今天直播人數你看又變少了
按個讚好不好
今天直播人數四五千人了
好不好
怎麼看今天只有三千多人
你就是傅信翰啊
好不好
需要我的時候才找我
還找我溫存
不需要我是不是不用了
好不好
OK嗎
貓德還在我的帳戶
還刪不掉
真的很慘
你看有人真的有
所以你看
這是老粉絲的
等於你在進入海嘯的時候
就在做股票了
貿易占物
因為下市了 散不掉
很慘喔
提醒你啊 好不好
提醒你這股票
不要單一全壓一檔個股
好不好
這KBF 好不好
請問整個世界怎麼看
世界你自己看 它是少數喔
其實為什麼今天反彈
我覺得沒有很精彩
我們看一下
沒有很精彩 不是3370精彩
台機店有沒有創新高
沒有吧
沒有嘛 台機店有沒有創新高
有沒有創這個新高
沒有
沒有沒有
你開始回答有還是沒有
沒有啊
沒有喔
沒有創新高
2535元
沒有突破是新高
好 我們看一下
2450連發
你說今天很強
沒有突破新高
很大部分的股票都沒有突破前高
我們拉遠
連這邊4970元的這邊前高也沒有突破
所以大部分股票都沒有突破新高
可是你看
5347 四間金金怎麼樣
有突破新高
沒錯吧
是
你現在這邊沒有買
沒有買到的
投資表你真的很可惜
四間金金我最近也買滿多次的
好不好
最近買滿多次的
所以四間金金怎麼看
好股票
來
我們來看一下喔
時間先進來
一個展停板
兩個展停板
昨天漲6.9%
有沒有看到
不是昨天
今天漲6.9%
昨天也是一度大漲
來
恭喜
來幫我念一下
來
好
6月30號
星期二
1.59分
恭喜
5347世界
股價一度大漲超過7%
再創歷史新高
我們多次買進
最高已經大賺51%
我持續看好它
手上持股獲利續爆
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
恭喜大家大家賺大錢啦
這都持續獲利續爆的
真的
世界千金你自己看一下
我們看一下
我們都實在的喔
賺51%
我已經說現在賺51%
真的很丟人
你看一下喔
散物就是這樣子
其實你會相信
真的這種行情
我不是說981也不好
我常常跟你講
981就是介於什麼
像主動的ETF
你自己看喔
台灣股市沒創高
它也沒創高
有沒有看到
有
是不是
是
因為它是個平均值啊
可是如果你選擇世界先進
或你敢重壓被動元件
你現在的股票就創新高
你就贏了00981A了
所以我說大多多的行情
其實有時候已經壓個股就好了
是
壓個股就好了
你懂不懂
你看00981A現在怎麼辦
跟0050差不了多少
而且005年的績效
最近還比098EA好
我要強調一件事
我不是要嗆人家
因為我發現
這些投信經濟經營的人
都會看我節目
所以算了
我只要告訴你
買個股比較好
那麼其實他們壓力也蠻大的
也算很優秀
優秀好不好
元納台灣50
有沒有看到
在這邊
這都是一樣
最近績效還比什麼
009EA好
沒有錯吧
還比009EA
好你看
看走勢图知道
00981A在这边
0050在这边
你看我很多
050还先创新刚刚不知道
我很多都讲在前面
那我们来顺便看一下这些东西
最近都有一些新闻
我们来看一下
台积电目标价
调升潮涌现
因为要下下礼拜
要法说会
下礼拜是要法说会嘛
是不是
3400 3300
7月16号
都有可能
为什么有可能
台积目标价我倒是去
為什麼我說我會看好七月
比如說你說六七千
展資長了六七千點
不是不可能
展了七八千點不是不可能
當然機率比較低
但不是不可能
我很少這樣講
什麼七八千點到一萬點
一個月內
我先跟你講
最大主因是什麼記起來
台積電目標價
我其實也上條了
當然我們不能直接講目標價三個字
那外資為什麼可以講
台灣的法律倒是很奇怪
你們剛才講說那個什麼
那個明明就有規定
外資不能協助目標價
結果外資天天洩漏目標價都不會被抓啦
我們還會被罰你知道嗎
莫名其妙他們都抓不到
我們分析師不能講過目標價三個字
你知道嗎
是
他們也不能講啊
但全部都講出去了
怎麼這樣子
我告訴你
我也不會講我的行動目標價
可是我告訴你
台積電是有機會
價格往上調的
我們只能這樣含蓄的講
是
來啦
為什麼我不要扯遠了
我不要講很多不公平事
在氣死人
不要講
3000 我跟你講什麼
我剛才講那個價格對不對
對
那個外資含到3400
那為什麼提高
我跟你講他們提高只是感覺而已
我告訴你為什麼提高
很簡單台積電要漲價
台積電不是只是說幾奈米
三奈米漲價
是先進之成全部漲價
我看你漲那麼多
你知道有人說
本來全世界最賺的公司是什麼
是什麼
是輝達嘛
現在不是喔
明年全聚最賺的公司是三星喔
因為靠記憶體
第二大的是輝達
賺最多的
第三大的是
是那個
海力士
很齊喔 都記憶體
台積電排到第幾名
第九名
這麼方便
可是就技術的一個
但是不同的東西啊
可是就技術的領先的來說
先進日程
贏第二名差太多了
你懂不懂
不像記憶體第一名第二名第三名不會差很多
台積電其實是有一個喊價的人力
台積電漲價我支持
台積電漲價下去
股價就會噴出去
所以我覺得在這邊
是有可能
你記得一件事
我真的建議你可以在行情噴出去的時候
在今年
這個現在是7月7月
因為現在已經6月底 最後一天
7月很簡單
7月可以再漲1萬點嗎
取決於台積電的法受惠
有可能
因為它可能告訴你說
不好意思
我們今年的營收
美元的營收
年營增可能增加30%以上
至少30%起跳
因為我們漲價了
那就會噴出去了
所以7月你可以再押保台湾股市
你們可以看一下
7月你可以再押保台湾股市
所以0050
來
為什麼
因為我覺得講的
當台積電的目標價
不要再講目標價三個字
好煩喔
我們很多那種
不能亂講的話
被限制
沒關係啦
不要說被限制
我們就是合法合規
只是有想到就跟外資比
我覺得會不開心
我遵守法律
他們都不遵守
然後還有一些網紅
都不用遵守
算了 報應是不能解決的事情
車遠了
反正我告訴你
到時候大家知道說
台積電漲價潮來真的
記憶體漲那麼多
我也要漲價
他們現在有傳出這個消息來
是
那真的到時候證實了
然後也算出來營收了
那不好意思
台積電的股價
就會很輕鬆的突破
來 記得有件事
下個月就有機會突破什麼
你如果是2800
那基本上你應該什麼
5萬點以上的
你知道嗎
知道
2800花掉
5万点以上
是
OK吗
5万点以上
好不好
大概这样子
所以你去想看
你要怎么试啊
我不去吃欧啊
我不去买欧炮
好不好
这是我要讲的
所以在这边而言
来来来
股票一定要记得我讲的东西
7月决定解决
7月16日的台积电法说
那我觉得他会讲一个
蛮大利多
我都講在前面好不好
那好 除了這以外我們來看一下
這台經電目標價
有沒有看到
賣給你啦 好不好
L11啊 哇 3500
以前都喊最高的
3500 3400 3400
我都不知道他的目標價是從什麼時候開始算
你知道嗎
OK
都紅色的
請四搖以後不要這麼單一顏色
這個不知道是German還是
應該ChairGVT做的 好醜喔
來來來
在這邊
這個應該不是要做
應該是威翰做的 好吧
我們公司團隊比較多人
他連發科也是一樣 1萬元
1萬元叫胡扯
用後年的EPS來算
你們外資不要寫這種目標價
寫這種目標價
我台積電台灣股市
我可以寫10萬點啊
有生之年一定來的幾
為什麼 現在5萬點啊
人家知道啊
前幾年台灣股市才1萬2而已
2022年
現在已經4萬8 漲4倍了
那為什麼台灣股市不能10萬點
不要說10萬點 20萬點也可以啊
我有生之年我也跟你打賭啊
要不要賭
有人敢說我賭嗎
賭一千萬嗎
我看沒有人敢賭啦
牛腦袋也知道我指的講是對的
所以你們喊一萬元的目標叫他幹嘛啦
你不能來個後年EPS嘛
這扯遠的
我跟你講
股票就這樣子
買低 賣高 買低 賣高
你喊一萬塊我丟給你嘛
是
一千四的時候台積電
一千四的時候聯發科根本沒人要
不要這樣做
OK嗎
這我跟大家講
好
那南韓大投資
全球記憶體業
壓力測試有沒有看到
那他不只投資什麼
他不只投資低論
Netflix這些相關也有
所以南亞科 華邦店 威甘群年
這台灣記憶體
相關業者全面警戒有沒有看到
好
8299群年
我問你一件事
漲漲值群年在利空啊
為什麼群年今天是漲還漲3%南亞科今天是跌你告訴我為什麼你們不知道就是我回答的買低賣高我問你那科漲多少那科從200多漲到500元了
是不是很誇張
是
你看喔
這大摩真的是反指標
一出一個報告人家要擴產
不要講反指標
可是真的
我不太喜歡大摩出去報告的方式
就是
哪邊牆馬上出去一個報告
比老頭顧還老頭顧
就哪邊牆就開始講哪邊
但是我還在講外資壓力也很大
雖然嘴巴這樣講講而已
包含那個投信
我還是覺得他們
很多同業在看
他們很辛苦好不好
嘴兩句而已
不會嘴而已
不是說真的要批評
因為我覺得大家都辛苦
只要不是故意害賞戶
我都可以接受
南亞科
1929 長到505 長那麼多
你說群年呢
群年前面有漲 後面沒漲
這邊有漲啊
後面根本沒漲啊
這就是我講的位階的東西嘛
擴產一定是個利空
但是你不擴產不行啊
你再不擴產東西生不出來啊
機體生不出來
然後無限漲價
大家會怪你啊
不是嘛 所以不得不擴產嘛
你聽懂嗎
好不好 所以在這邊
可是擴產後是個利空
為什麼群聯漲
為什麼南亞科疊
位階 位階 位階
這樣懂不懂
670利基電
它就漲啊 為什麼漲
因為這一波它也沒漲多少
有沒有看到
前高 創新高 有沒有看到
那你懂不懂
比較了解了沒
那我們看一下滑斑店
滑斑店
滑斑店算少數還算強的
但是也沒到多強啊
你懂我意思嗎
那我跟大家講
還是後面才拉起來一點點
大部分股票都是位階
位階高的就比較容易下去
位階低的就比較容易上去
所以你要把握位階的節奏
OK嗎
understand好不好
今天股票真的操作不錯
來 再看一下
來來來
群裡沒什麼正常
萬宏今天最好下
大家都展就他跌
沒有 南亞科也是一樣啊
南亞科是我的股票
我們看一下萬宏
萬宏 萬宏是今天從頭爛到尾啦
萬宏也是快不行了
怪怪的
所以記憶體現在比較分歧
OK嗎
來 今天直播人數4700人
算還好
怎麼看最近的無人機話題
我不懂 無人機有很多話題
等一下要講清楚
你們不能丟個大哉問
是中國的無人機
還是台灣的無人機
還是台灣的無人機均購
不回答啦
讚讚讚 我愛美元起噴了
謝謝大家
群狀會不會後續抗展
群狀不是我股票
但我說群狀的籌碼很漂亮
要拉隨便可以拉啦
你不要說68啦
拉到90塊
100元都有機會
好不好
OK
這怎麼看技嘉
來技嘉第一家啦
這微星
微星拖到尾盤耶
微星我賺到了喔
如果沒記錯的話
微星我還有買喔
我是不是說
我前天跟你教學有沒有印象
Liddy
有
我這邊是微星的位階
對
這是那個技嘉的位階
有沒有講
有
這是技
是
第一家 技家第一家
這微星的位階
你看今天拉起來
微星拉這一根很特別喔
我認為中食屋大物
吃完貨要走了喔
來問你一件事
為什麼微星
你們很奇怪
你們都問我說
嘴嘴啊為什麼
至少部分人
我不知道是為了要
叮嘴嘴還是怎麼樣
你們做不到的事情
為什麼要為難我呢
不要說你們做不到
分析師們通通做不到的事情
就是永遠賣最高點
做不到
如果做得到的話
拜託你告訴我是誰
我用1000萬加入他會員 好不好
我是認真的
不會有這種人啦
表演是表演
可是我跟別人不一樣
我所呈現的就是我實際的生活
就是我們實際的操作績效
來
我們講說很多人
我們講完很多人說
哲哲那個聯發科
你那個賣掉賺100%多
很厲害
但為什麼
你有沒有賣高一點
就賣很高了 不然咧
對啊
那國際哲哲你們賣高一點
我賺100%我想走行不行
問你為什麼低的股票你不買
只要微信漲很多
來來
叫做媽的看周線
以前多少錢
210有沒有看到
去年210耶是不是
是
那我現在我可不可以從100元找200元
可以啊
還沒創新高耶
100元找200元賺一倍
為什麼我們不能選低階的股票
低階的股票啊
不要選高位階 選低位階
我剛才講的位階很重要
我從今天一開始的韓國股市
台灣股市
台灣為什麼殺這個尾盤
殺到433點
位階的重點
是
所以我告訴你微信為什麼拉起來
位階
所以我就是进一些
比较低位階的股票嘛
微星看起来
我有闻到
你知道
你们闻到的味道
什么味道
赚钱的味道
闻到了
你们配合谢谢
真的赚钱的味道
好不好
赚钱的味道来了
微星就不要喷了啦
好不好
低位階的股票
这个整理很久耶
微星完以后
不小心
我们反正按技嘉
不小心按到微星
技嘉是今天早上就拉了
可是技嘉在拉不代表什么
为什么
技嘉拉只是还在这个位阶
还在这个位阶你知道吗
还在这个位阶
所以这我讲的是技嘉的一个走势图
技嘉还在这个位阶啊
你懂我意思吗
什么意思
就是说技嘉今天长不用开心
他只是昨天多跌
把他拉起来
回到位阶
他不是说突破这位阶在这边
他不是在這邊你知道嗎
所以股市操作就是這麼簡單
不要去想那麼複雜好不好
OK嗎
Lily脖子紅紅的有嗎
你們這樣子不要
暗示他什麼東西好不好
好好
來啊
來
這跟大家講
這個好笑超配合
微星最近被難打規模大的ETF
納入成分股
不錯喔
有在認真
有在認真喔
好不好
鴻海要不要先走
換其他會展得太久
紅海就算我要走
也是我會有的權益
我都暗示你了
對啊
趕快好不好
這紅海最近上新聞
不要只是上高爾夫球的新聞
哼哼哼
哼哼你有什麼想法
不會人家創
郭台銘都已經離開紅海了
這個不影響股價
沒什麼想法啦
這個人家的八卦事情
新聞我就不討論了
好不好
來
這個跟大家講
我也不太會
我也不太會打高爾夫球
我比較沒時間啦
郭台銘以前年輕的時候
應該也不打高爾夫球
比較不會那麼慘打
好不好 也沒時間
所以不去理人家的事情
整個七月會上五萬點嗎
阿信最近都很晚來
然後都問一些奇怪的問題
我剛才不是說有機會
取決台積電法說會
台積電法說會
會講到展價題材
因為展價題材一定會提高他的毛利跟營收
OK嗎
這跟大家講
好不好
3035资源怎么了
哦
你们这些看起来都不是会员的
对啊问我怎么了
我不懂然后怎么了
今天涨啊
然后怎么了
他也没有很弱啊
他前阵整个弱这一次还好啊
我觉得还是在一个很漂亮的区间
甚至有机会创新高
那我们最后来看一下我们的股票哦
其实今天股票大部分都涨了
微星
最后樊圈樊圈
看一下我的樊圈
刚才4000千金不是涨51%吗
还没走哦
而且穿歷史新高喔
穿世界歷史新高
哇聽起來真的很厲害
很厲害
穿世界歷史新高
是
穿世界新高
股價穿世界新高
聽起來很厲害喔
來來
維新賺22%
好不好
維新回檔的時候
我最近就買維新
所以我跟你講喔
我們維新喔
因為我們最近有些清代會員
我們通常清代會員會買
三到五檔股票
大部分是三檔股票
是
普通會員是希望他買
五檔股票按照簡訊的順序
都會定時發一個訊息
那特別會帶到三大五檔
大部分三檔
那我們有時候三檔
分三檔過票
可是有時候我會動作慢
可是這幾天我動作很快
尤其昨天跟上禮拜
你知道嗎
因為昨天跟上禮拜
貴買指數跌
所以我買得很開心
很多人就買到微星了
好不好
這是我認真的說法
不是微星之論
OK嗎
也不是那個心情之火
心情之火不就微星嗎
對不對
房軒也是一樣
賺了58%
你看
所以行情好或不好
至少可以確定一件事情
雖然你今天殺在尾盤
但是至少韓金好的時候
你很多股票很容易傳新高
帆軒再一根就不得了了
帆軒是非常非常強勢的股票
這帆軒
3374精彩也是一樣
好不好
這跟大家講
所以我們再休息一下
再跟大家講3374的精彩
好不好
好
休息一下
還要講更多的標股
今天好多標股還沒講
那剛才那個三大重點
不好意思
這個都講的
7月長1萬點
為了莎士爾30點
好像都講完了
是
還有別的利多
還有那個自駕車這一塊
會影響AI的股價
我們休息一下
馬上回來
投資長
那個期貨剛開牌了
您是怎麼看的呢
那我們來看一下
期貨我們來看一下
這個期貨看一下
瞇一下
跌121點
這怎麼看
我沒有怎麼看
你看你有沒有笑
一會增加它會逆價差
你看這跌的剛好
46125點
你看現在跌100多點
現在跌100多點還比它多500點
代表增加差600點
是
你們可以cundum嗎
不要動不動長個5600點
現在很難做事情耶
你看一下
來來
講到同時空單是不是6400口對不對
是
是喔
趕快找重播
我昨天有沒有講說空單會大增
有
我昨天就有講今天空單會大增喔
我說突兀8萬口喔
所以今天又突兀利息高了嘛
所以外面只能講外資空單
外資空單
外韓的看熱鬧
內韓的看門道
那些很多人都外韓
就連分析師還是外韓
我昨天直接講今天創立
今天怎麼樣
股價怎麼樣
今天股價增價差這麼大
就是期貨比現貨多個六七百點
七八百點什麼意思
那一定會有人去做套利嘛
套利穩穩賺
你看現在00981A
台灣50
你都沒有辦法創新高
那我寧願去選擇穩穩的套利
那也是好幾億元
好幾十億元的生意
而且是基本上是快要穩賺不賠的生意
我做期貨
然後做多台股
或做多全值股個股
或直接做多台灣50
我這樣就可以多賺這700點
700點一口我就賺14萬
我這樣說有沒有錯
請視角找一下
是不是歷史興高
是啦
還沒有 歷史第二高
上次也是七八百點的時候
這邊有沒有
會不會
836005口
但是我昨天有沒有說空檔會大增
有沒有講 有
有 今天空檔增加6000多口
都講在前面喔
來 我們看一下
來
那個四瑤 我也要講
歷史第二大 這我知道了
不用等你打
OK
外資今天賣5億多
好不好
這只賣5億多怎麼會殺尾盤
No no no
他可能本來是買300億
最後一盤賣350億
或是305億
所以最後變成賣五億多
好不好
這是一個淨
一個淨
一個淨的值
相減過的一個值
OK嗎
這跟大家講
好不好
所以你去想想看
你要只要跟分析師
我也不去試的話
我也不去買Hopo
所以你看期貨
我昨天就預告了
我都預告在前面
環球晶我也預告在前面
我很多次都預告在前面慢慢來賺自己該賺的錢買這種精彩慢慢來乾突破錢高的股票是不是精彩你看看周線圖
你不要看喔
你看喔
這前年的時候精彩
也快300元了
所以會很貴嗎
前年的時候283元
現在286元
經過了兩年時間
所以你覺得精彩會很貴嗎
一點都不貴
之前一點都不精彩
所以就像微星一樣
微星為什麼現在要拉起來
因為之前它有200多元
請問你146元會很貴嗎
你知道3037星星
是爭議最大的股票
我之前最好笑啦
還有人被人家慫恿啊
說哲哲
你是不是注意
故意跟誰配合讓我們賠錢啊
天啊
星星120元賠到70元
就說我故意讓人家賠錢
那現在呢
我故意讓你賺錢
然後你只要跟我道歉
不要鬧了
真的不要鬧了好不好
拜託同意也不要鬧
我們還是強調就是
每日一次
如果要攻擊分析師的分析師
基本上業績不會很好
跟我說一次
因為業績好像我很忙
我們沒時間看人家
是
好不好
如果你說你
你如果說你績效很好
我很厲害
我操作多厲害
你操作多厲害
那你應該說不完會員
幹嘛攻擊人家
對不對
基本上攻擊別人
業績不太好
績效也不會太好
我只要告訴大家
至少攻擊的時候
最後的下場是什麼
不要下場兩個字
結局是怎麼樣
你們看到了
自己公司的財報營收衰退了
第二個
視網網剝離了
某一位分析師就這樣子
心血管堵塞了
心血管阻塞了
要開大刀
我真的希望他身體健康
我是跟你說認真的
所以同業要改變投顧的肉息
那20年前的肉息
不要去攻擊同業
我沒看到一個攻擊同業
真的業績又比較好
因為這樣業績比較好
一位都沒有
你說20年前有機會
你知道為什麼20年前
攻擊同業有機會嗎
為什麼
因為以前比如說我
電視台
非凡 哪邊電視台
兩點看完只能看兩點半
兩點半看完只能看三點
所以他們有很大連結
大家選擇不多
現在沒有大家都網路時代
你跟我我跟你沒什麼特別關係
而且網友看得
網友很聰明
看的是你賺不賺錢
來看一下
我昨天也重播了
你看一下
我昨天播了
6月29號對不對
是不是
來看一下
沒有聲音喔
為什麼沒有聲音
唉 能怎麼辦呢
這個是
那個又是
靜靜初心
等我一下
來來
當然不管怎麼樣
一個好的公司要管理很多事
你看連這個小事情
整個都要去管
好扯遠了
3 2
昨天講對不對
我講說這個不是散戶做多
其實是散戶做多
當然是外資在做空
你別忘記我看我昨天講
至少今天又增加差不多500多點
這代表一件事散戶瘋的
這台子旗
我認為不是外資拉的
台子旗我不認為是外資拉的
我還是說外資要做空
聽清楚
拉的
就現在很多小散戶
還買期貨 還壓期貨
賭很兇啊 你知道
變成很大增加差
我們看一下今天空單
今天空單只有減301口
我覺得明天還有機會再減更多
好不好
因為太好做增加差了 OK嗎
你拜一龍之前210
我覺得有
你看有沒有
是不是
這空單我昨天是說怎麼樣
還有機會更多
因為就賺價差嘛
所以今天台子期跌137
133點
我覺得還好
因為還是期貨是46,646點
還是比大盤多500點
是不是平常新貨OK嗎
慢慢來跟大家講這些所有的邏輯好不好
只得不去伺候化也不去馬後泡
來我們看看
看完有沒有什麼問題
沒有問題我們今天差不多結束了好不好
看這個看這個
來
今天的量在你的眼光來看是否足夠推動後續
量都騙人的
我可以舉一大堆啦
高膽爆量
結果台股一直穿新高啦
這邊有沒有高
這邊我問你一件事
我隨便舉一個
台股
你看喔
新高在這邊嘛
沒錯吧
對
新高在這邊嘛
對不對
48,000嘛對不對
是
請問你這邊有沒有高膽爆量
有啊
爆滿爆量啊
是不是
是
這量價很重要嗎
量價很重要嗎
是不是
上升的過程中
很多都爆量啊
這邊也爆量啊
只是量比較縮一點點
一堆啦 高檔爆量
又不會怎麼樣
是不是這邊高檔也是爆量啊
380,000 這邊
我畫歪了 對不起
所以在這邊而已 你有沒有看到
今天你說指著反彈沒有量
那沒有量 散物比比差啊
指著你說散物比比差
又有些散物拉的
有部分散物比比差
部分散物不用怕啊
所以我跟大家講
這反彈也沒什麼
所以我就說要整理一個禮拜
一兩個禮拜過後再晚上沖
剛好搭配什麼
台積電法說會啊
是不是
是
大家就不啦
好不好
該跟大家講的好不好
哲哲
謝謝
我們來看一下網友講的
哲哲善良
只有自保
從不攻擊同業
當然啦
應該說不主動攻擊
不主動攻擊同業
該回籍還是要回籍
該找律師還是要找律師
你知道嗎
該找律師
對方就告來告去
那個律師
我不是搞到心肌梗塞
然後射黃玻璃嗎
最後要告我的時候沒告贏
也不願找律師啊
連律師費都省
那你還說不怕我告你
要幹嘛啦
是不是
是不是 你聽懂嗎
不知道
我還去比一下
我想一件事 這兩件事
大家都可以看到有眼睛
我想一件事
我在工作
我現在工作不是為了
不是為了錢
如果為了錢
我應該把1.7C的美債換掉
換到現在台灣50
我至少可以賺到4億
這是事實 我少到2億多
第二個我捐救護車
一台就快五百萬了
我之前還有什麼
捐兩百萬給慈濟啊
給什麼的
我關公開的捐錢就一兩千萬了
公開的
我私底下又捐一些錢
好不好
所以我沒有在乎那些律師費
我只希望大家好好賺錢
扭
把心力花在網友室門上面
所以真的每日一講
好不好
謝謝哲哲認真貼心為父
謝謝你們
我也愛你們
請問哲哲飛龍是否不在影響
應該說飛龍影響不大
除非今天飛龍數據很差
然後是個趨勢性
那等下要看
就像CPA那時候是趨勢性
同胞是趨勢性
目前為止不重要
所以就是這樣子的數據
好不好
被告那個人現在身體
真的非常不好
你也知道對不對
我們為他欺負
真的為他欺負
你不要每天氣我嘛
氣到最後氣的是你自己身體
我講沒錯吧
氣郭忠
你幹嘛
要告我
你幹嘛要告我
我為什麼不告你
你就亂講話啊
是啊
你真的是為了正義嗎
說穿了還不是為了利益兩個字
我構成的國不夠有名
你會這樣子毀謗我嗎
唉
這很多東西都是以正視聽的
好不好
這段頭長開大過後
我覺得聲音都怪怪
聲音被板住感覺
沒有 我還想太多
都回覆差不多了
好不好
我的兩義跟哲哲兩義是不太一樣
你的兩義
你有兩義那麼多嗎
好啦 失憶了是不是
好 開玩笑
來來 好啦 扯遠了
我們不要講那些同意的事情 不重要
扯扯融資會殺到斷頭嗎
其實這是我講的一件事
散戶現在最大的問題是
他們不會緊張
他們覺得台股永不跌
日不落國 日不落谷
我覺得不太可能啦 好不好
來來來
新的攝影機 攝影機角度有點妙
會覺得不好嗎 不好再跟我講
我是覺得人太大了
那個人看起來太短了啦
小人到時候這麼短我會生氣
你知道嗎
你自己看這個畫面然後就切
太短了啦
幹嘛上班上班很短你知道嗎
莫名其妙
看起來矮了一個這樣子
我都不懂為什麼你們沒有美感可言
這都要念他們沒辦法
好啦 扯遠了
來
來 私意跟回意啦
來來 先跟大家講
一一幾分的 一一想要聽出來
好啦 扯遠了
所以今天股票講的喔
我們今天很多股票
其實真的很強的
來
我們來看一下
微星
這個線圖
看起來知道一副要噴了
好
這一個
前
這一段
這一個階段
目前為止
我最喜歡兩檔股票
帆軒
跟5347
世界先進
你看今天穿的力量新高
賺50幾%
還賺多少%
我懶得算好不好
所以這些股票
就是這樣子好不好
帆軒有沒有看到
然後技嘉
好
學生
技嘉有沒有
喜歡持股獲利虛報
統治上表示本益比太低了有沒有看到
我持續看好他
一堆股票我今天是
創新高或大漲的
房仙漲5%
然後賺58%有沒有看到
都比那種什麼台灣50巷的股價強很多
比主動是ETF
我們就不要講誰
那不是重點
也不要亂攻擊人家
比主動是ETF
現在技巧好很多
維新也是一樣有沒有看到
我們就很靈活啊
世界先進賺51%有沒有看到
這都是一樣
五萬美元今天暫停
然後環球金大壯82%還沒走
聯發科也賣得漂亮
你想清楚
告訴大家
七月來了
六月你錯過了
六月漲那麼多你已經錯過了
你不要看今天這行情
我們看一下六月
那個利益
六月你要不要統計一下
六月你知道統統的點吧
六月漲了5806點
然後說錯
五月漲5800
六月漲了1300
是
5月漲了5800
如果7月份我跟你講
不要說1萬點
漲個7000點好不好
7月份漲7000點
是無可能的
他很瘋狂的
可是你要把握住
所以你要去想想看
你要漲完粉絲
取決於台積電的法說會那種
可是問題台灣股票也七七
很多很貴
台積電反而相貴
對沒有那麼貴
雖然台積電本益比
跟以前比算高
但跟其他股票比
那差很多
所以你想清楚
你覺得7月我要壓寶
再7000點
或者在壓寶 像維新
像很多低基期的股票
像時間進行之前很低基期
直接像噴起來
很多低基期股票的話
歡迎來您下行
您806885
或加爾賴私信我
您錯過這個月的1800點的行情
1300點的行情
也錯過了5月份的5800點
錯過4月份的7000點行情
不好意思
7月會不會錯過7000點行情
如果你不想錯過
今天不論是什麼
台灣No.1
還是我愛美元
這兩難蓋排股
今天通通盤中都有漲停
尾盤怎麼樣我不告訴你
我如果新的蓋排股或這兩難股票
你想要進場的話
歡迎來臨小型
0806-8085
或叫我來私訊我
不論對我或所有者
這一切就要到前面
去香港人家的分析師
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
謝謝各位
我愛你們
本节目资料仅供参考
投资人应独立判断
审慎评估并自负投资风险
谢谢大家